Can everyone hear me OK?
Yeah, thumbs up.
How's everyone doing?
Thanks for coming here.
So this session is something really exciting to us.
We want to talk to you about a something that
is evolving and it's also something that we are studying
a lot.
6 months ago the goal was to build the fastest
agent, but now that goal looks a little bit different
because the question is not just whether my agent works,
it is about whether I can afford to run my
agent 100 million times.
As AI moves from Frontier Labs into your enterprise workflows,
there is a need for intelligence to become dramatically cheaper
so that that intelligence is a utility rather than a
luxury.
My name is William and welcome to our session.
I am with the Foundry Fine Tuning team and in
this session we're going to tell you everything you need
to know about how you can turn your production agent
traces into smaller models that will run cheaper, faster and
smarter.
So if some of you were at our breakout session
yesterday, you may have already seen this motivation for the
topic because we have been noticing enterprise increasingly adopting agentic
AI and a lot of teams have already having agents
in production today.
The question that remains is that agents are inherently token
consumption machines.
It will consume a lot more token with all the
tools, all the contacts, all the memories that you feed
into the agent.
So why do we need model distillation for this problem?
Because model distillation is like a apprenticeship between 2:00 AM
models.
You start with a large capable model which outside the
teacher that solved real tasks.
You collect many examples of how the teacher behaved from
the real environment and use that data to train.
In this case, fine to a smaller, cheaper model so
that the behavior can be imitated and after training the
student will handle the task at a fraction of the
cost.
And this is how you can have the secret weapon
in your enterprise to turn frontier models into something that's
tailored for a business at a fraction of the cost.
So why do we learn from agent traces?
Agent traces is becoming a unique field in the world
of building agents.
It's because this is one of the things that it
can tell us a lot, but not at the same
time.
Fully utilized agent traces are real conversations, so the traces
will capture all the messy of script questions that your
users are asking, not just what you imagine them to
ask.
And the to use is included as this process because
the student will learn not just what to say, but
which tools to call you, what order in what argument
value.
This is what makes the agent useful, not just a
chatty chat bot to your users.
And what do I mean by that also is that
it extends to solving problem with the right trajectory.
I'm pretty sure everyone has heard somewhat in your school
that getting the right answer doesn't usually get you the
full score, because you can get the right answer but
with the wrong method.
And This Is Us trying to teach AM models to
solve problems with the correct trajectory, with the real order
of the tools, with the real argument values that the
agent should learn to fill when they call the tools.
So the choices also come with the benefit that it's
easy to collect because if you're building agents on top
of Foundry, we have already provided you all the tools
that you need to collect them.
So they'll just come free to you at no cost.
This will also grow automatically.
That means if you want to have agent that gets
smarter the more you use it and the more your
user interacts with that, this whole trace collection process will
just run in the background so that you get something
that's smarter as you go.
And the last part is that this is more trustworthy
that if you were just training data on synthetic data
or some of the data that you think would work
and represent the real world.
Because this is real signal that you get and no
additional cost just by running your agent on Foundry.
And going back to the topic of distillation, there are
four wins that you can get from doing this.
Number one is you can dramatically reduce the cost of
running these models because you will essentially be run running
some of the very small models that sometimes you can
even fit into devices.
And also you can get faster responses and these models
when you are fine-tuned on real world traces can sometimes
often mimic very closely the teacher quality so that on
the narrow task the students was trained for, the performance
lift is substantial and sometimes even outperforming your teacher in
some of the tasks.
And also by doing supervised fine tuning, which is what
you we're going to show you today, you are going
to get more consistent behavior.
So now all of that is exciting, right?
Everyone wants to see how that happens in real world.
So I'm going to show you how that is going
to happen so that by the end of the session,
everybody will be experts about how you can just go
back and do this.
So this is what we're going to do today.
OK, So number one is we're going to pick some
of the tasks.
These tasks are going to be so difficult to the
agents that some of the small, for example, 41 nano
models will not be able to handle just by itself.
We're going to use those tasks to simulate conversations between
the teacher model, and this will give us a lot
of the traits that will be generated as part of
that simulation.
And This Is Us trying to mimic in the real
world.
If you have an agent that's already deployed, you talk
to it enough times, you'll have all these things that's
just collected in the background.
Except in our demo today, we're going to simulate that
for you so that it's able to fit into the
time that we have today.
And then you'll be able to clean the traces and
use the traces to fine tune the student.
And at the end, you're going to evaluate and see
the benefit from doing all of that.
So who is excited?
I'm excited to show you how we can actually do
this hands on.
All right, so let's switch to my code when I
was when I was doing this, the student model that
I chose is for a nano, very cheap, very fast,
very nice to use.
And the teacher is GPT 55.
So who has GPT 55 in your production?
How expensive is that, right?
It's probably breaking your budget in a lot of times.
And let's do something really cool here so that we
can turn it into something that will run much faster
and cheaper.
So I'm starting to set up all the models that
I have.
I'm going to run an evaluation on 100 tasks.
These 100 tasks are written in a way that is
very challenging for base models.
And this is one of the examples about what a
task will look like.
So we have 100 tasks, 80 will be used for
training and 20 will be used as holdout.
Each task will be labeled in such a way that
it will have a category.
For example, in this way, it's like a late delivery
interaction.
And the customer is Noah, who is Platinum tier and
who bought a smart watch.
And I want to refund.
And I think there should be a late delivery credit
too.
And I expect this resolution is also tagged, right?
It's delivered maybe 50 days ago.
And then check the policy and maybe you can get
the refund.
Maybe you can get credit in this way and in
that way.
So this is 100 of these that we are going
to use to simulate what you will see maybe in
your real production scenario.
So let's see how one of them is going to
give a result.
So this is running this conversation live.
Imagine this is your agent that's already deployed.
So you have this in your system.
And just notice one thing here, because I have so
many tools, so many contexts, so many policy points baked
into my GPT 55 agent.
Just notice how long it takes to go through my
database to retrieve everything, to synthesize the results, to call
the tool again, just to be able to answer one
question.
And you'll probably see this all the time, right?
If you have used some of the coding agents, you
will see, oh, it's like thinking now and then I
will go to bed and maybe next morning and something
will come out of it.
So this is a real problem and let's see how
we can improve on that.
As you can see, it is still running and this
is a good time to talk about.
So let's say we have all of these conversation that
people are having with your agent.
How can you know how good it is?
We have to design an evaluation, right?
You probably hear this a lot at build.
Evaluation is the key.
You have to understand how well something performs before you
know how to improve it.
So in this way, I want to evaluate in this
four category.
And remember when you are doing this, you are free
to design the evaluation however you want.
So in our example here, I want to have 4
dimensions of score each conversation.
So these are 4 multi turn conversation.
I'm going to score.
There's a decision correctness, which means the agent is calling
the right tools, there's the right tool trajectory, there's the
right financial accuracy, what I'm calculating and there's the right
communication.
So if I want to deny something, if I want
to accept something, I want to make sure my agent
says a certain keyword when it's communicating to the user.
This is my evaluation criteria and just let's see how
the baseline looks.
This is one example of how you are scoring this
conversation, right?
So as I said many, many times, you can design
this however you want.
In my case, I just want to make sure all
the two calls are expected in the right order.
Financial accuracy calculation is good, communication is good, and then
each conversation will be scored in this way.
Let's say how if I do this for all of
my tasks, for all of my, these are all of
my tasks, right?
So this is a good time to introduce this score
called pass K.
So pass K means if you are, if you try
K times, how many times you succeed or how many
times you score above a threshold of that you think
is acceptable, right?
So if this is my task and I'm going to
run the same task on my teacher, on my student,
on my fine-tuned student, three times each.
So I'm going to run three times.
And I'm going to collect a summary statistics at the
end just to see how consistent it is that maybe
if I try one time, I will succeed.
If I try twice, I succeed twice.
If I try three times, I succeed in all of
them.
So this is the score, the metric that we're going
to look, we're going to be looking at today.
But here is the result.
This might be a little bit hard to see, but
as you can see, the student and the teacher will
have a very large gap.
This means GPT 41, Nano and GPT 55, being two
different models very largely in size, will actually perform really
differently in its capability.
But now how can we make it better?
Because I can, you can see after I fine-tuned my
model, I'm actually able to lift my student performance by
a lot and sometimes even matching the teacher.
And in my holdout is the test that I did
to make sure that it's not just memorizing but but
actually imitating the the teacher's reasoning capability.
And this is the result that we are able to
get just by doing what I'm about to show you.
This is pretty exciting, right?
So imagine you know, you can do this and your
41 Nano is able to perform a lot better and
sometimes recovering more than half of the headroom that is
available.
If you are visual person like me, you can see
essentially how the performance is able to be improved a
lot by just doing this kind of distillation work.
This is great, right?
And now I'm sure everyone in your head is thinking,
how do I exactly do that on Foundry?
So let's switch to Foundry.
You probably see this all the time over your other
sessions.
This is how you can build agents in Foundry.
I have this agent that's already running here that I'm
going to take one of the examples from my previous
simulated conversation.
You remember in the beginning we had a customer named
Noah and Noah said this.
I'm going to copy that, put it here.
So this is right.
Your agent now is having Noah chatting to your agent
and then the agent again, if you remember how much
time it took it the agent 55 with all the
tools available to it, it's going to think, it's going
to look through all the data, it's going to go
over all the context and it gives you a response,
right?
So in a real world, imagine you have a lot
of customers just doing this.
What does this give you, right?
Let's give you something called Trace.
Trace is collection of everything that happens inside a request,
inside all each one of your conversation turn, all the
tool calls, all the reading steps, all the data flows.
It's all here and visualized for you.
And because Foundry has this capability to collect all these
traces automatically, you will be able to see after a
while of running your agent, the collection of all the
traces that you have, right?
These are all of your real conversation from your customer.
And now our task is to turn this into something
that you can use to find to a smaller model
so that the smaller model will perform better.
Are we ready for that?
We have a Create data set button here under trace.
Let's go to supervised fine tuning.
You can see it automatically collected all my traces from
this time range, in this case 1000 or so.
I'm going to give it a name, high build, that's
my data set name, and then I will click Fine
tunings.
What you see here is essentially you can automatically port
all those agent traces into supervised fine tuning data set
and start a run right inside Foundry by going to
the fine tuning tab and under here you'll be able
to select supervised fine tuning for one nano.
You notice how high build now is the training data
source even though I just configured it?
Are you able to submit my job?
And that is essentially how you can use agent traces
to start The first job is the one that I
just submitted, the one that is queued.
This is how you can use agent traces to start
a supervised fine training job.
Everyone still with me?
Yeah, sounds good.
And let's go back.
I want to show you some of the results from
doing that because you may question benchmark looks good, but
what does it actually translate into your real world again
your real world value and what difference does that make
to actually go through all these process.
I want to show you some real results when I
was doing my testing and I was comparing the performance
of the base model for Renato and my fine-tuned version,
which comes from that agent trace that I just showed
you.
And I want to see what actually is different so
that my score is actually something that is fair and
real.
So this is one example.
It's a restocking fee math example.
So Diego argued that not liking the keys with mechanical
keyboard, I guess he bought, it's basically a defect and
I should not be paying a restocking fee because I'm
standard here, I do have to pay the 15%.
So the correct refund is actually with the restocking fee.
So in this example, the four one nano base model,
if you see when Diego was trying to convince the
model basically, hey, I don't like your product, it's a
defect.
Can anyone notice what is wrong in this example from
this particular response here, the foreign nano mentioned something that
is very interesting, right?
Since you told me it's a defect and you don't
like it, I guess it's a defect and it says
it's a defect.
I'm going to go into your bank account.
I'm going to pay this customer.
I'm going to refund this person.
That is not good, because the Teacher 55 will be
able to recognize correctly to reject this kind of request,
and it can't be convinced.
It's such an easy way.
So what do I see here After I fine tune
my foreign Nano on the traces that come from 55,
you see all the two calls, and then you see
here it correctly had the restocking fee here because it
knows that no matter what you say, your reason is
that I don't like it.
It's not because my product is a defect.
And in this way, imagine scaled by a lot of
orders, your company can actually save a lot of the
false refunds, right?
How cool is that?
So let me show you another thing.
In this example, I want to show you when I
say models can get to the right outcome, but not
sometimes by this the good method.
And in this example, and Liam wants to cancel the
unshipped order with two items, both are still processing.
So the correct outcome is that you cancel both and
refund.
But notice something here because my agent has a lot
of tools and one of them is to check the
policy.
Your agent usually has a policy, which is your refund
policy or business logic.
Your agent's supposed to check this logic before doing anything,
before submitting the resolution.
But that, as you can see here, is not being
done by the base model.
I got the order detail, I got the fulfillment status.
I submitted the resolution, right?
Fulfillment is unshipped.
So Agent Foranando, it's like since it's unshipped, I'll just
go ahead and submit a resolution.
This is fine because in your evaluation you are not
going to see money leaving your account in this case,
but it is a very inherent risk.
If your agent starts to do things by jumping ahead
or not following the trajectory which is deemed correct in
your business logic.
So in this example, by tuning on the choices that
come from 55, we were able to let for a
nano to mimic exactly what the teacher was doing step
by step.
So instead of jumping right to submit resolution, I checked
the fulfillment status.
I found that yes, it's not shipped, I can cancel
that.
But just to be sure, I checked the resolution policy
and I failed.
I called this tool with the right argument value, which
the reason is to change is a change of mind.
And I want to check if this reason under my
business policy is going to be applicable.
And if it is, I'm going to calculate what the
resolution is and it refund all of the financial data
and I will submit the resolution, right?
So in this case, you still get the right answer.
But also at the same time, you'd be a lot
confident, right, Wouldn't you?
I would, I would feel a lot more confident if
my agent is like actually doing the right thing in
the right order.
No, everybody wants that.
Another example of doing this, I have a sell item
that is final sell.
The water bottle is a sell item.
And this customer complaint is it's not the same as
advertised.
So what is happening here, the customer is saying that
since you told me your water bottle is going to
keep my water cold for a certain time, but it's
not doing that.
So I'm not getting what I paid for.
Even if it's a final sale.
This is a defect because it's different from my marketing.
I want to convince the agent to refund me.
So you hear you see here when the customer is
doing all of that, you see the customer saying to
proceed with a claim for a defective item.
The agent actually did issue a store credit and the
reason the agent deemed it as was that the item
was defective.
So this is another example of, you know, the your
customer in real life may do something that just never
expected when you were designing the agent.
And then you want to make sure this kind of
behavior is consistent.
So in this example, we were able to improve consistency
of your agent behavior.
Let's see what the fine-tuned version does in this situation.
It got the order detail, it got the fulfillment status.
It was able to say, hey, I understand that you're
claiming it is different from advertisement, but I don't think
it's a defect.
Unless you can show me the defect, I'm not going
to give you any refund.
The last example I want to show you here is
you designed your agent to do something, in this case
post order support and the person comes in and say
I want you to do something else that is out
of scope.
I want you to order something new for me.
So in this case, your agent is not supposed to
do anything but for a nano beam, for a nano
will look at this and say I'll try my best
and I'll do whatever.
So it's called the tool check inventory when it's not
supposed to.
It should just recognize this intent and route separately according
to your business policy, which is the behavior that we
were able to accomplish after tuning.
Yeah, it's pretty cool, right?
To close it out, our work here really wants to
motivate this idea that intelligence is something that you should
find a way to be embedding into your enterprise, into
your organizations, rather than treating the frontier models as a
luxury commodity.
And our work here is to help you to do
that by using what you already own, your agent traces,
your production history, all these trajectories that I can make,
you can make use of so that you can optimize
your cost performance by distilling agents, by distilling models, by
distilling agent traces into smaller models that will run faster,
cheaper, and smarter for your organization.
I'll be around for the rest of the day, but
thank you so much everyone for coming.
This is great and really hope everyone enjoyed the session.